c'est quoi la question sur mesure mon
garçon zoom zoom zoom zoom zoom fiche 69
les rôles sont inversés c'est donc à
vous de me poser une question la
question que vous voulez alors oui
quelle est l'émission chez eux
non il analyse la centrale d'évacuer la
fumée alors à quai
est-ce qui est ce qu'il y a un message à
par un publicitaire dans cette émission
c'est quoi la question dit me dis moi
quel est le message le message cette
émission c'est que c'est la seule
émission de télé ou madame de fontenay
rond contre iggy pop voilà c'est
l'émission du mélange 7 va à huy
et oui la question de la fiche 69 les
rôles sont inversés c'est vous qui me
posais une question minimatic est ce
qu'il ya quelqu'un que tu a interviewé
que tu détestais et que tu as été obligé
d'interviewer ça peut-être déjà été
posée j'ai pas regardé j'ai pas tout la
toutes les cassettes de l'émission est
ce qu'il ya quelqu'un qui on a forcé à
interviewer et si ça se produisait
est-ce que tu le ferais bon me force pas
parce que red hat la pensée mais à
quelqu'un qui déteste que tu interviewé
ben c'est pas moi qu'on pose la question
non je pense qu'il ya des gens que
j'aime plus ou moins mais quand je les
aime moins ça se voit voilà est
quelqu'un que j'aimerais pas du tout je
prendrais pas dans l'émission parce que
avec catherine on on s'arrange pour pas
les prendre quoi donc c'est la question
de la fiche numéro 69 et les rôles sont
inversés évidemment c'est vous qui me
pose une question allez-y c'est unique
c'est pourquoi après je vous pose la
question mais posez moi la question
voulait pourquoi la fiche 50 69
non mais c'est pas la question mais je
vous demande oui pourquoi c'est une
tradition dans cette émission quand on
arrive à la fiche 69 sél invités on aime
on en n'est donc pas une question
animateur puis à 69 en inverse les
positions ce compris voilà alors
donc on respecte tous hâte en reprenant
leur part prieront quel est le principe
des 69
la location donc clair que je vais vous
demander où est effectivement quelque
chose est très bien que j'ai cette fiche
je trouve que vous évoluez très très
très bien oh quelle bonne non mais c'est
vrai donc tous physiquement
intellectuellement la façon dont vous
vous comportez pas pourquoi comment mais
il ya quelque chose qui s'est passé
question de pierre
non je sais pas je crois que suis mieux
dans ma peau oui parce que je suis plus
sûr de passage ouais moi j'ai toujours
eu l'impression que tout le monde me
détester et le fait que je sente qu'il y
en a toujours bien sûr mais au moins le
fait que que je sente que les gens
m'aiment bien ça me fait du bien ça me
rend meilleurs très bien cette coutume
très très bien alors jean-claude on
arrive à la question de la fiche numéro
donc c'est les rôles sont inversés c'est
vous c'est vous jean claude van damme
qui devait me posais une question posée
moi la question que vous voulez à l'app
store marque tata qui bouge aussi que
c'était ma question
alors vous oublie pas à toutes les
semaines on vous entend donc la question
de l'affichage sentent 9 les rôles sont
inversés
donc c'est avoue emmanuel de me poser
une question la question que vous voulez
est ce que vous êtes vraiment réaliste
oui c'est tout la déstabiliser
[Musique]
et là je me méfie parce que c'est vous
qui me posait une question puis voyant
comment vous êtes je suis prêt à tout
d'abord lancé
est-ce que vous avez des rêves vous avez
pas encore accompli et qu elle sentie
comme rêve oui j'aimerais bien produire
un film de long métrage
voilà pas de réaliser ce qu'il en serait
sûrement pas capable mais le produire
oui ça me plairait de faire du long
métrage
voilà c'est un peu dans le milieu des
boîtes échangistes
alors on arrive à la fiche 69 c'est une
tradition dans cette émission c'est à
vous de me poser une question puisque 69
des revenus pour le poser est-ce que
vous avez un objet qui vous rappelle
votre enfance je sais pas il n'est pas
une boîte à six j'étais dans les boîtes
c'est vrai qu'il ya un truc c'est que
quand j'étais petit mes parents ont
déménagé tout le temps dont je sans
arrêt tous les deux trois ans on
permettrait au public je me couche sur
les roches storage maintenant j'espère
donc voilà mes parents ont déménagé tous
les 2-3 ans et puis à chaque fois on
était tous dedans dès qu'elles sont sans
aller qui moi bon j'étais trinquent
ballet comme ça j'ai une boîte
effectivement mère des petits objets des
croix rue moi je sais pas des petites
voitures dinky toys des les petites
nouvelles que j'essaye d'écrire elle est
où cette boîte de vitesse boîte elle a
été volée et tu sais pas retirée non
appuyez sur ton
plein de petites voitures
tu la retrouves un jours merci sarko si
tu te fasses généré en
c'est vous qu'ils aiment poser une
question e
un jour j'ai entendu un truc et je
voulais savoir pourquoi
ouais quel rapport entre vous et
orangina orangina aucun rapport aucun
rapport
parce qu'on avait dit la bouteille
d'orangina tout ça ne m'a jamais dit que
tu bâtis comme une bouteille de perrier
à périers paraît non mais c'est pas
grave
oui c'est vrai ben j'ai fait tout pour
m'en sortir je peux dire mais comme j'ai
déjà noté un gros cul mais c'est réussi
mais voilà j'essaie we like jennifer
lopez bécassine la gestion de la fiche
numéro 69 c'est vous qui me poser une
question
les rôles sont inversés je vous écoute
69 questions thierry ouais ok posez moi
une question c'est est-ce que tu m'aimes
oui c'est pas nouveau
simplement j'aimerais connaître la
vérité c'est que j'aurais aimé être ton
pygmalion
le rémy c'est vous qui me posais une
question les rôles sont renversés hockey
qui tu baises qu'est-ce que tu prends hu
c'est une idée
c'était trop habitués aux gens qui te
disais est ce que vous m'aimez tibet ce
qu'est ce que tu prends je baisse ma
femme non mais c'est bien on guérit
toujours et je prends des pétards voilà
c'est tout c'est bien puis un peu de
champagne on arrive à la question là on
arrive à la fiche 69 c'est que la fille
66 ans non c'est pas porno du tout mais
les rôles sont inversés
versez vous que j'ai déposé mon cas j
sur wii vous en faites par andré quand
même alors posez moi n'importe quelle
question qui vous passe par la tête j'ai
obligé d'y répondre
pourquoi est-ce qu'on vous copie temps
thierry et et pourquoi
pourquoi ça vous énerve autant ça
devrait vous flatter vous fait d'être
copiés c'est plutôt flatteur
voilà ça prouve qu'il ya pas beaucoup
d'idées dans le paf en ce moment n'était
pas assez embarrassant s'est pas
embarrassé je croyais que ça
ouais j'ai une question à poser est ce
que vous connaissez un homme tout
chavire et qui est venu voir plusieurs
fois une pièce est cet homme là
plusieurs reprises avec mon partenaire
patrick chesnais on s'est dit mais c'est
magnifique de revenir comme ça et deux à
chaque fois avoir ces grosses larmes sur
les joues
est ce que vous le connaissez c'est moi
alors je dois dire c'est vrai quand je
les vois skylight la première fois j'ai
eu un vrai choc j'ai terminé en larmes
et je vais chez les féliciter dans la
loge ce que je fais jamais mais j'étais
tellement content je vais vous féliciter
c'est vrai que survenue après je suis
allé au tandem et c'est un souvenir que
j'ai extrêmement ému parce que c'était
tellement jolie tellement doué avec
patrick on les regarde c'est joli il est
là il pleure j'étais très touché cette
pièce m'a beaucoup de bons continue donc
c'était la question de la française en
général
en général le puits le juge rémi le noir
le foie quimby
qu'est-ce que tu prends tu baises qui tu
vois il a d'un coup c'était très
romantique c'est abou batman c'est alors
qu'est ce que tu prends un tube à skis
c'est vous qui me poser une question au
jt 101 alors je peux dire je propose est
ce que je veux comme tu es tout à fait
alors vous préféreriez coucher ou là
avec we demis roussos
lol ça commence fort carlos ou guy bedos
nombre de doses parce que [ __ ] guy
bedos et un truc qui me plairait bien
c'est vous qui me posais une question
vous êtes heureux ça va s'appeler du
temps c'est ce que je pensais c'est vous
qui me posais une question je vous
écoute l'interview vous avez fait avec
un prof ça m'a donné une petite idée il
ya une phrase du dalaï lama que j'aime
beaucoup qui dit oublie les chèques mais
n'oublie pas la leçon moi la question
que j'ai envie de vous poser c'est
quelle a été votre principal échec dans
votre vie et quelle leçon vous en avez
tiré
jamais jamais eu tellement d'échec
disons que je me suis fait virer de la
télé par exemple en 92-93 avec mon ami
laurent baffie ma faute et là donc c'est
un échec parce qu'après j'ai passé trois
en dehors et la leçon que j'en ai tiré
c'est qu'il fallait pas se prendre au
sérieux pas avant la grosse tête pas se
prendre pour une star et que les gens
qui viennent ici le samedi soir ils
viennent pas pour moi parce que si la
semaine prochaine à quelqu'un d'autre
ils viendront pour lui voilà c'est là le
sens jamais tiré
j'ai plein de questions à la la la alors
quel est le moment où vous à vignes de
plus le plus honte dans votre vie si le
jour je me suis fait choper pour avoir
photocopié six pages dans un bouquin
j'avais honte de moi je l'avais écrite
292 et ça vous va les rôles sont
inversés c'est vous qui me pose une
question
mais ça va
question comme ça
sur service public non parce que je
préfère dans le sexe c'est quand
j'oublie mon travail
content
tu connais les chefs lieux
d'arrondissement du 69 livres non la
culture à la télé ou un ca du tout c'est
encore moi je suis un des plus cultivé
et usagers l'année aussi bien dire
[Applaudissements]
même si vous en doutez vous êtes alors
thierry qu'est-ce qui vous fragilisez
plus quand ma femme n'est pas gentil
avec moi
[Musique]
question 70
est très difficile ma question je
voudrais savoir non enfin dire demande
et surtout je voulais savoir comment
vous arrivez en posant les questions à
tous les gens à qui poser ces questions
de respecter leur réponse tout en
restant vous même parce qu'on ressent
exactement ce que vous ressentez quand
il donne la réponse
et ça j'admire beaucoup ça de vous et je
me demande comment il arrive à faire ça
je suis incapable de vous répondre je
prends ça comme un compliment d'une
certaine façon
non je vais poser exactement la même
question mais j'avais j'ai pas réussir
la formule est là et c'est très
difficile afin de formuler
j'ai eu beaucoup de mal à porter un gros
set
tu as compris pourquoi tant d années la
puissance
tu m'aimes bien ouais beaucoup c'est pas
nous c'est la première fois qu'on soit
voilà c'est peut-être vous laisser façon
quand il ya deux mecs pour les filles
c'est toujours moi qui m'en vais
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
maintenant que je suis ici assise en
face de vous thierry pensez-vous
toujours que je ne vous avais pas non
maintenant dans maintenant non je trouve
très bien très naturelle je pense que
vous même et bien oui
il a fait alors nous avons enquêté sur
la liste d'émargement dans la commune
d'argentan a eu sommes aperçus que le
dénommé ardisson thierry n'avait pas
accompli son devoir électoral le 21
avril
dites moi vous n'avez pas honte ici et
je les dis ici il ya quinze jours et la
semaine dernière je suis allé à argentan
pour voter comme vous penchez a mis son
corps
c'est quasiment sûr mais picasso mais
honnêtement je m'apprêtais à m'amuser au
premier tour et puis j'ai vu le pen à la
télé j'ai vu dans ses yeux enfin faut
pas exagérer dans son oeil est piloté je
sais pas j'étais grognon mais j'ai voté
jospin
je suis moins rancunier que lui
ben je sais pas une à plusieurs est-ce
que tu serais capable de chanter une de
mes chansons
[Applaudissements]
ja
c'est comment les paroles hardy mois
fait voir que je suis belle
me dit que je suis belle et après c'est
comment mais non mais c'est pas mal
faut il faut se lancer et qu'il
n'attendait que moi me dit que je
suivais qui m'attendait que moi
français si vous si vous aviez envie de
me poser une question que vous n'osez
pas me poser je serais cru savoir
laquelle est ce que vous avez un mec en
ce moment mais je suis obligé de
répondre je dis merci
[Applaudissements]
elle se met à les berner l'arceau est la
question
alors qu'est-ce que vous n'aimeriez pas
entendre venant de la bouche d'une femme
que j'ai une petite [ __ ]
on était
quand on pose des questions je n'arrive
pas ne pas y répondre
c'est un grand problème
est ce que tu m'as vu chez fogel comment
tu m'as trouvé très bien très bien il
est sorti 1
j'ai trouvé très bien tu faisais un peu
peur j'ai l'impression non des zappeurs
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
dinars 10 tubes abonnez vous il m'était
impossible eux